So Dave Robinson did a kind of
live analysis of this dog breed
data, and he made a
Shiny app out of it.
So maybe I can walk through
what it looks like in Py Shiny
and just try to translate
some of that to Py Shiny.
So I watched him
work with this data,
so I know a little bit about it.
And for some context,
I think there's
a little bit of cleaning that
has to happen and then some
reshaping.
The interesting
thing is I understand
there's three pieces of data.
You have these breed traits, so
this is for each breed of dog.
It's ranked or I think it's
rated on a number of things
like, how good are you
with young children?
Apparently, Retrievers
are really good.
Norwegian Lunderhunds
are not the best.
Then there's the
trait description.
I think this is a
pretty wild one.
This is a just written
out description.
And I actually love this like--
so for affectionate with
family, if you get a five,
it means you're lovey dovey,
which I find to be just great.
Yeah, so Retriever's
lovey dovey.
And then breed rank all.
This is a little bit different.
This is like from 2013 to 2020
or 2020 rankings of the dogs
basically over time.
What we can look at is maybe
comparing dogs across traits
and working on a Shiny
app that lets you--
because there are
a lot of dogs here
if you look at the breed traits.
So it'd be nice if
a user could choose
the dogs they want
to look at and be
able to compare them in a plot.
There's a little
bit of wrangling.
Here's a weird
thing, I can either
wrangle it in siuba or pandas.
For me, siuba is the most fun,
and I'm pretty used to it.
So basically, this
is a port of--
let me change from
dplyr to Python.
And I've kind of come
to rely on it as a thing
that just kind of
wraps pandas and does
a little bit on top of pandas
to make life a little easier.
So the way it works
is pretty similar
to dplyr with a
couple of twists.
So for example, if I want
to find a dog that's not
very affectionate with family--
these columns are crazy,
I may have to fix that.
But I could do where it's one.
So the Anatolian Shepherd
dogs, apparently, they're
very independent.
So the key with siuba
is that with dplyr, it
would look pretty similar.
You'd have a pipe and then
you'd have this just by itself,
something like this.
So the big differences
are now, the pipe's
like a greater than
sign, and we're
using an underscore rather
than referring to the columns
directly.
This is useful because
it's way easier for me
to just keep thinking in
dplyr than to kind of switch.
And it's not that
different from pandas.
Pandas would be
like, breed traits,
affectionate with
family, and then you
do something like this.
There are a few ways to do it.
So it's kind of like there's
always like a pretty simple--
the translations to
pandas aren't crazy,
but it just cuts out
some writing basically.
The other useful
things-- and I'm
cheating because I
saw Dave with this.
But for reshaping, it'd
be nice to tidy this
so that a lot of
these columns become--
to go from wider to longer.
So it'd be nice
if a lot of these
were a column called measure
and then these things
were a column called say value.
One of the big
things we have to do,
though, is that these
are all numeric,
so it makes sense that
we could reshape them.
We've got to drop
things like this
that use a different
kind of measurement.
So do select.
And I use the minus
sign to remove things.
Actually, first, I'm
going to I think clean up
these column names.
So there's a pyjanitor
library, which is nice,
that can clean names.
Or I guess we can see
it'd be something like--
I always forget how to do this.
I think you could
do something like--
this is crazy but I think
this will do basically
to sneak case.
Let's see.
I need something bad.
Columns.
Yeah, so this is pretty
gnarly pandas code,
but the trick is that this
gives you back index of columns.
And then indexes and
series and pandas
have these string methods.
So you do string that
lower and then you
can kind of keep going.
So I would probably just use
in other situations, maybe
pyjanitor.
It's nice in the
tidyverse there's
just a clean names function
to get rid of a lot of this.
But I'm just going
to define it here.
Oh, that's bad.
He's going to put it here.
I think I'll just mutate it
because life's too short.
So that should do it.
I should return it.
And well, I have black
formatting setup,
which gets kind of weird.
I might turn it off.
Oh, it's bad.
I got an auto format code
when save the notebook.
I think that will do it.
Let's see.
OK, we're back.
All right, sorry,
so that's weird.
So that's what's doing a
lot of this formatting.
I don't really know, the
weird thing between our Python
is I'm not really sure how to--
it's kind of nice
you can quickly--
One funky thing about
Python is to do the pipes
with nice format.
You kind of got to use these
parentheses around them.
So I'm just going to pipe
this using this pandas method.
Sorry, this is kind of crazy.
So it's great.
So now, we've got nice formatted
names, and all of that's
just so in this select, I can
now just drop using code type
and drop chord length.
So I think now we have
everything and we can reshape.
So what I'll do is gather it.
So the first argument is
the name of the new column
that all of these will be
put in, so these names.
And then the measure column.
And then I think that we
just say everything we want.
So negative means we want
everything except for the breed
column to be reshaped.
So now we've
gathered the trades.
Now, we've taken all these
columns and basically--
I don't know how to use
human words for that.
But so now, each measure
is right here, so
each of these cells
and now the columns
are in this measure column.
This will be useful
for the app because--
let me call this
traits long, I guess.
This makes it a lot
easier to select things.
Now, we can just filter
to keep specific columns
or filter to keep
specific breeds.
So I think that's
the big deep layer
thing, is like before
we could filter by breed
or select a column,
the beauty of gathering
is now we can filter either of
these things, breeder, measure.
I'm going to rename
measure by trait.
So all right, great.
So now we have this data,
we can visualize it.
I'm going to use plot nine.
So plot nine is a
port of ggplot two.
It's super nice.
I think it's been
around for a long time,
and it's a super
faithful report.
So basically, all of this is
me trying to squint my eyes
and produce what seems
like tidyverse code.
All right, so let's see.
Let's just traits long ggplot.
Actually, we need to
filter it probably,
so let's get just
maybe a couple breeds.
So I'm going to use the pandas
method isin, so that's like,
get it from this list.
So let's say Labrador,
Retriever, Scared French,
Bulldogs.
Let me double check
if that worked.
Something bad happened.
I wonder if this
is a little bit--
I need to somehow
see it as a list.
OK, so this is a weird thing.
This is a great data
wrangling problem.
There's a character that
appears as a space but isn't.
Sometimes, you can
Google these things
and it'll show people, will
explain what is happening.
But usually, just
string replace them.
So let's see.
I'm just going to do it, yeah.
I'm just going to remove or
replace space or something.
I could call them--
I don't care.
I'm just going to
put it in the mutate.
So let's put it here
for now just to see--
So we selected, we gathered,
let's just replace it
here and see how this goes.
Equals string replace.
I think it's just this
character and then
let's see if this works.
So yeah, visibly no change, but
I'm guessing this will let us--
let's see.
Yeah, great, that was
a real scary issue.
Cool.
OK, so this got it.
And then so I'm going
to filter, maybe it's
going to keep say like
affectionate, family,
and good with young children.
So we could format this.
It's using this Jupiter--
what's it called?
Jupiter Code Formatter library.
Cool.
So now, we've got two
traits, two dog breeds.
We can plot it.
So you plot on the
x-axis for the trait,
y-axis for the value.
And then I'm going
to make a bar chart,
and then I'm going to
make breed its own plot.
Let's take that.
Oh, something bad happened.
Oh, I'm sorry, geom-bar
counts up the values,
geom-col makes a column.
OK, so this isn't
super exciting,
there are fives
on both of these.
But this is maybe
a nice example,
because there's a lot
of room for improvement.
So one thing I like to do is
fulfill the breed or the trait.
This just kind of
re-code's this information
but makes it easier to see.
And then the other weird thing
is this text is horizontal.
So we can change
it in the theme.
I think it's axis-text-x.
And then this is kind of tricky,
ggplot being element-text,
angle is 45.
And then the last thing, this is
probably the most common thing
I do in ggplot is notice
that it'd kind of be nice
if this end character
matched up with this,
and I think that's
just hjust equals 1.
Honestly, this very snippet,
I use so much that I just
reflexively slam it every time.
So we've got plots, we did
a little bit of cleaning,
a little reshaping.
So this is something
Dave did, I think
this would be a nice kind
of starter for a Shiny app.
We did a little analysis,
we made our plot.
But now, it would be
so nice if we basically
could select the breeds
and select the traits.
There's this weird thing, if you
watch people build Shiny apps,
actually, I think the
most intriguing part
is they often have
analysis code somewhere
and then Shiny app code.
I think this is actually one of
the hardest parts of starting
with Shiny is the workflow,
having your analysis on one
side and your app on the other.
Do I have jupytext?
No, I don't.
Let me install this really fast.
What I often end up
doing is using jupytext.
So this is the code.
What I can do is--
say jupytext.
One thing I like to
do, sometimes, I just
put the Shiny app at the
bottom of the notebook.
And the way I do
this is you can pair
the notebook with something
called light script.
And notice that when I save
it, it produces a Python file.
So now what happens
is basically,
I just want to keep
exploring, but I'm going
to tuck a Shiny app down below.
I don't know if
this is a good idea
or if it'll even work but--
and I'm going to add a
section like exploration.
The trick is that now, I have
my exploration code up here,
and Jupiter has this
nice table of contents.
So I just marked like, oh,
this is my exploration code.
This is my app, so I
can jump between them.
And then what I'm going to
do is I'll just scaffold out
a really tiny Shiny
app, and then I'll
just run the whole script
because life's too short.
I kind of want to just
do the exploration
in the app in the same place.
I'm going to copy
out maybe from the--
I mean, this link won't exist in
a month but just this tiny app.
So the key is like, this
doesn't do anything really
because Shiny needs the CLI, the
Command Line Interface to run.
But it's kind of nice
it's all in a notebook.
And then what I'll do is
I'll run it separately.
You can also do this in the
JupyterLab terminal, that might
be a good exposure down there.
But dog app.
So I'm just going to run--
Oh, I don't remember
how this CLI works.
Shiny run.
I think I'll keep
looking at the help docs.
So the thing is I
want to run Shiny run,
but then I also want to run this
reload so that it auto reloads.
So Shiny run
analysis.py and reload.
I might need to also set
the port depending on--
OK, so basically,
what's happening now
is it executed this notebook.
So just to back up this
notebook through jupytext
is now saved also
as a Python file.
Every time I click, Save, it
syncs with the Python file.
Shiny CLI is just
running that file.
And the reason
that's useful to me
is I'll just put a lot of
exploration code in here,
and I'll define
the app down here.
And then I'll just
check over here
to see what the app looks like.
And it's kind of convenient
because a lot of Shiny apps,
I just dumped this
stuff straight in.
I can kind of dump
it in and then
I can clean it up and
move it into its own file
if it's useful.
So for example, we
already have traits long,
so I could just
even put this in.
Let's do a render.
Let's see.
Return traits long.
So where we are right now is
that rendering tables is still
in the works.
So right now, it's
rendered as a UI.
Let's just see what happens.
I'll drop in the plot instead.
So let's see.
So I'm just going to
dump in this plot code,
so just paste it in.
It's here.
And I think this
should just show up.
I'll do render
plot, output plot.
I'll change this.
This Isn't a table anymore,
this is a trait graph.
This trait graph, see.
It still has this row of input.
So I'm not seeing anything,
and that tells me probably
that there is an
error or something.
So I'll look here, I
don't see anything.
It's probably something I did.
I think I didn't return it.
All right, so this is the graph.
We have this kind
of useless input.
Now, we have this
hard-coded thing.
What I'd probably do
next is I'd swap out
these hard-coded things
for a dynamic input.
So if you do input and
get selectors, and let
me call this traits.
So this is the label that'll
show up on the input.
And then so many
options, choices here.
So we can do is multiple
equals true, choices equals--
what we could do here
is we could actually
set these as the
choices to start just
to make sure things wire up.
Let's just see that it worked.
Cool.
So the choices are here,
they're not wired up yet.
But this is a kind
of a nice, I think,
for me sanity check
that it's ready to go.
And so now, I'll just swap
out this for input.traits,
so this thing here,
just to link it up.
Yeah, so the move was kind
of like, I set the choices,
I copied the choices
from here to here,
and then I swapped in
the interactive piece.
Cool.
So now, we can see I can
toggle it, just great.
This is still kind of
boring because I just
hard-coded two choices.
So a nice move here is you
can actually just hard-code
the choices based off the data.
So if I go to
traits-long.traits.unique,
let's show this.
OK, so this just gets
me each unique trait.
And then the last
thing I need is Shiny
I think wants it as a list.
So I'll just use this
pandas method to list.
So what I'll do is I'll probably
do options traits or something
trait.
Options trait.
So now, it's all of
the traits in the data.
So now, we can see for a
French bulldog or Retriever,
different things that--
I'm going to make
this a little bigger.
So we have the traits wired up.
Let me go ahead and try
to set the breeds now.
So I'm just going to do the
exact same thing but drop
in breed.
So let me put this
trait, maybe, and paste
in the exact same thing.
You need unique.
And then because it worked
out OK for the other,
I'm just going to jump
straight to it and put .breeds.
So this is not right.
So I did something
bad, let's see.
Oh, I put the traits here.
So options breed.
Yeah, that's cool.
I'm partial to beagles,
do we got corgis?
We got multiple kinds.
Yeah, I love that
Pembroke Welsh Corgi seem
a little more affectionate.
Cardigan Welsh Corgi is a
little bit too independent,
I don't know.
Yeah, that's nice.
I think the
autocomplete is great
being able to search super fast.
[MUSIC PLAYING]